jordan or lebron who's the goat jordan
yeah
okay
like i said man bro you my dog you know
this though be a brave video arguments
about this though does he take that does
he like is he conscientious about that
[ __ ] laughs at that [ __ ] bro he's like i
feel like he is in the conversation why
the [ __ ] does i mean i feel like he is
the conversation he's getting compared
to michael jordan though we having real
life arguments in barbershops about
who's better between him and mike so let
me ask you this though he gonna get bad
for he don't get mad bro that's what i'm
saying about brian that's raw as [ __ ] to
me because me personally i would be like
mike gotta play me one on one [ __ ] all
that we streaming this [ __ ] right right
right let's let's cause cause for real
for real i lowkey thing mike's so
competitive bro mike could come out of
retirement right now to play
and take a l
calm down maybe take a serious l you
gotta k you ain't uac mike hoof in a
while i i don't need to see it
right now lebron versus mike right now
dog do you know how mike jordan you
ain't never seen it though you've never
seen mike just i've seen michael jordan
in person no you've never seen him just
sitting down and just get up in his
street clothes
no i've heard about it though he does it
all the time bro and every time you
think like this thing can't dunk no more
but don't you think lebron has had the
level of competition has been a lot more
insane for lebron are you being serious
right now very much so
you're being dead serious bro okay
you're being dead serious right now do
you know what michael jordan had to deal
with bro
you for real we can go over his finals
opponents and go over lebron's finals
opponents and you tell me who had the
tougher teams you tell me who lost
okay that's fair
but he also played
the trailblazers
he played what was wrong with the
trailblazers i mean the trailblazers
ain't they have more secrets
they have a super team
lebron had to play it's a dick sucking
statement lebron had to jesus christ
this is only a statement that a retired
iman shepard could make
i'm just saying we talking ball
all right so listen so lebron had to go
through and oh
in o5 he had to play
peak or was 07 rather was it 0705 you
went to the finals against the spurs
he's been up quite a few times well the
first time he went against the spurs
that was the first kind of
incarnation of the spurs dynasty before
kauai right so that's like peak mining
so you think mike and scotty wasn't
going to blow that out we just beat the
spurs 4-0 and sent them the [ __ ] home i
don't know man we just shook pop hand
like a great guy
i think i think y'all the cavaliers
would have swept the jazz
first we're not talking about the
cavaliers but the bulls didn't sweep the
jazz
it was a it was it was a serious series
we got lebron james we can match up with
the jazz
i could get over a screen we could deal
with john
that he played a thunder team with kevin
durant russell westbrook and james
harden in the finals
we could have matched up with that with
the bulls fam
think about it we got ron harper six six
i like who was gonna guard mike on that
thunder team
it wasn't gonna be kd he don't want to
do it yeah who was gonna guard mike what
i'm saying who was gonna guard him so
you think that because scotty p was
gonna guard campaigns
scotty p was on guard kd mike was
defensive team he was gonna take russ
who we gotta deal with james harden off
the bench sixth man okay
see i'm saying who gonna deal with cool
coach when he come off the bench at 6
11.
we coming to party bro
so you mean to tell me you
so cute you think that's so cute give me
something
you need something you think the bulls
had tougher competition in the finals
i'm saying lebron don't violate the
bulls bro do not compare these new teams
to them bulls bro i don't think y'all
remember how them bulls played listen i
don't think y'all remember i watched i i
i don't think
i got to the nba i got to the nba
watching these [ __ ] they wasn't
playing with these people they're not
going to play none of these games none
of them you don't remember when gary
payton was giving us a hard time what's
phil do hey scotty
deal with this man 94 feet
i like it i like how he speaks as as as
a wii perspective for with the bulls
what you mean we're not good we never
win we not we not having it yeah
it's got to be dope to see the bulls be
good again right yeah we wrote oh
they're
we we cold to seal right now and
speaking of we the cavaliers are cold
again
mobley's abs are doing a great job
moby's but that's not we oh so okay so
once you're not a cavalier for life
you're watching i'm a cavalier within
the 16 team
i don't know these new guys i feel like
you're like i don't go to war with them
okay because i feel like cleveland will
always look at you as like wanted like a
like cleveland
you said the cavs though see so no they
traded some they traded chum yeah 2016
cavs love them
everybody else [ __ ]